[Musique]
et tout de suite
l'himalaya nous accueillons ce matin est
dit larry une personnalité singulière de
l'alpinisme bonjour aide
bonjour après bien d'ascensions de
l'everest ont été tentées il y en a eu
au moins 10 avec pourquoi ont-elles
échoué à cause de mes avec un cône
cirque un sport pensez vous qu'il soit
possible de grimper l'everest
oui je suis convaincu que c'est faisable
je suis persuadé que ça se fera un jour
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui lie à seulement 60 ans
mais c'était à
totalement différent l'idée d'être le
premier à conquérir le plus haut sommet
du monde
c'était en quelque sorte comme dénicher
le saint graal
[Musique]
il s'agissait d'une course pour
atteindre le sommet le plus haut du
monde
la grande bretagne n'était pas la seule
nation en lice mais c'était vraiment sa
dernière chance de remporter ce
challenge
ono ça va si on pouvait survivre à 8800
40 mètres d'altitude tout comme pour la
conquête de l'espace
il s'agissait de briser les frontières
il ya une limite physiologique à ce que
l'être humain peut endurer
les membres des cris sur le sous
continent où les attend un willy le
chef-adjoint impatient de voir débuter
cette aventure nous sommes ravis d'avoir
achevé la première étape de l'ascension
de l'everest
nous allons pouvoir nous concentrer sur
les hauteurs si le temps est clément
vers la fin du mois de mai juste avant
l'arrivée de la mousson nous devrions
pouvoir atteindre le sommet
[Musique]
on
fou
[Musique]
dans
j'ai rejoint d'expédition pour la
première fois à l'ambassade britannique
de gamins en deux nous étions treize
membres occidentaux d'officiers
supérieurs de l'armée dirigées
l'expédition
je n'avais jamais entendu parler de lui
auparavant rencontré pour la première
fois à katmandou je tenais à être
entourée d'hommes que je connaissais
déjà
c'est pourquoi je me posais beaucoup de
questions sur ed
quoi qu'il en soit dès que je les
rencontre et j'ai su que j'avais en face
de moi tonkin dont l'influent ce serait
déterminante
c'était un véritable pilier monsieur
hillary juste par curiosité depuis
combien de temps pratiquez vous
l'alpinisme je dirais depuis une dizaine
d'années
combien d'expédition or de nouvelle
zélande avez vous réalisé j'ai déjà pas
couru plusieurs fois des maliens et vous
avez eu une éducation assez strictes
n'est ce pas
j'ai grandi pendant la grande dépression
ma famille n'avait pas beaucoup d'argent
à cette époque je n'étais qu'un petit
gars de la campagne
un apiculteur c'est ça je travaillais à
la ferme
prévente grande aventure de montagne
quel contraste non entre l'apiculture et
la halle crise pas frémi quand j'étais
apiculteurs je porte est constamment des
caisses de miel de 36 kg mon frère aussi
était apiculteurs et ont rivalisé
constamment je pense avoir conservé cet
esprit de compétition dans l'alpinisme
[Musique]
l'équipe s'est d'abord réunis à 80
dollars nous avions 17 jours de marche
devant nous pour arriver à den bosch où
nous allions installer notre premier
camp de base nous avons ainsi traversé
plusieurs hautes crêtes et vallées
profondes
cela nous a permis de nous mettre
progressivement en jambes et surtout de
faire connaissance et de constituer un
esprit d'équipé
m
pour moi
non
tout avait été calculée dans leurs
moindres détails cette tonne et demie de
matériel 443 paquetage tous numérotés et
dont le contenu de chacun étaient
minutieusement listées à l'allumette
waligny près c'est une expédition en
équipe qui se présente vraiment sous
forme pyramidale
l'exposition compte 13 membres
occidentaux grande sherpa réside en
haute altitude
ce sont les hommes qui l'ont porté les
charges jusqu'en haut et près de 600
porteurs népalais qui ont acheminé notre
équipement à travers le pays et jusqu'à
la zone d'ascension
[Musique]
comme il y avait déjà eu pas moins de
sept tentatives britannique sur
l'everest
nous estimions qu'il était normal que
cette montagne soit gravi par le royaume
uni et par extension le commonwealth
les suisses avaient failli atteindre le
sommet en 1952 et les américains étaient
les suivants sur la liste
il y avait donc beaucoup de pression sur
les épaules de jo tout le monde
s'attendait à ce que cette exposition
soit une réussite
[Musique]
non
monsieur larry combien y at-il de néo
zélandais dans l'expédition de cette
année nous nous sommes que deux georges
lot et moi même georges lot et mon père
étaient de grands ennemis ils ont
largement parcouru les alpes du sud de
la nouvelle-zélande ils formaient une
très bonne équipe d'alpinistes mais il
était très proche
nous avons fait dix-huit jours de
trekking durant lesquelles nous avons
appris à nous connaître
même s'il y avait toujours un peu de
taquineries envers les néo zélandais ed
et moi nous avions fréquenter des lycées
ordinaire tandis que la plupart des
autres membres étaient allés dans des
écoles privées
[Musique]
nous venions de milieux très différents
ça ne faisait aucun doute
[Musique]
katmandou népal mule de 120 mètres au
dessus du niveau de la mer l'everest
démarre lui à 5500 m notre marche
d'approché de 17 jours était une étape
essentielle dans mon processus d'
acclimatation
c'était une vraie course contre la
montre nous avions constamment peur de
l'arrivée de la mousson
c'est pourquoi johnson a annoncé nous
devons être en mesure d'entamer
l'ascension de l'everest au 15 mai plus
mais avancera plus nous aurons de chance
de subir la mousson c'est vraiment une
course contre la montre
[Musique]
à mesure que nous gagnons l'altitude
notre excitation augmenté nous
commencions à distinguer deux grands
pics et les surplombant tous se trouvait
la grande pointe de l'everest à
seulement 32 km mais aussi à 6000 mètres
est soutenu monsieur larry vous avez
commencé l'alpinisme en nouvelle zélande
oui c'est exact
voici le mont cook surnommé le
personnage qui salissent majestueusement
vers le ciel à plus de 3600 m j'avais
décidé avec un ami de faire une
excursion au mont cook plus nous nous
approchons plus j'étais impressionné par
ses magnifiques l'italie si ce n'est
donc les offres aux amateurs de la
pratique un du meilleur m et d'alpinisme
hors d'europe
cette nuit-là à l'ermitage nous résidait
deux jeunes hommes sont entrés et
j'entendais de l'agitation autour d'eux
il venait d'escalader le mont cook sega
profité du elle s'avère l'impression de
mener une vie triste sans aventure sans
rien d'excitant
c'est alors que j'ai décidé de me mettre
à l'alpinisme
[Musique]
au bout de 17 jours notre convoi est
arrivé au monastère de tale of a plus de
3600 mètres d'altitude
une fois remis sur place
il a commencé à faire très froid les
porteurs originaires des plaines
n'avaient pour la plupart que des
vêtements en coton
ils ont donc été payée renvoyés vers
leur village et ce sont les porteurs
chirac qui ont continué certains des
sherpas qui est poursuivie l'expédition
avait déjà une certaine expérience
mais ce n'était pas le cas de la
majorité des zigs était une exception
il avait beaucoup d'expérience en
matière d'alpinisme en fait ils avaient
plus d'expérience avec les vrais cette
banque
sur le char tu avais pas gravir
l'everest mon père était le m
les gens le respectent et ils savaient
qu'ils réalisaient l'ascension de
l'everest avec des étrangers depuis 1935
il y était déjà monté six fois vous
savez je connais certaines une de
réputation je savais qu'il avait fait
beaucoup d'alpinisme et qu'il était très
respectée malheureusement je n'arrivais
pas vraiment à communiquer avec lui son
anglais était très limité et tout comme
en mai palais il avait un sourire
étincelant vraiment charmant il était
impossible de ne pas l'apprécier
les 15 jours suivants
nous avons eu une période d'entraînement
pour nous tester nous et notre
équipement d'altitude en 1953 on
ignorait complètement si l'on était
physiologiquement capable d'atteindre le
sommet de l'everest
c'était comme envoyer un homme dans
l'espace
on savait grâce à des simulations en
chambre que l'altitude pouvait avoir de
graves conséquences
on craignait surtout les risques
d'hémorragie cérébrale sans raison de la
dilatation des vaisseaux sanguins de
nombreuses raisons portait à croire que
cela provoquerait en abaisser nos
personne ne savait vraiment si c'était
faisable
wen s'est lancé dans l'ascension en 1953
treize personnes étaient déjà mortes
dans la montagne je pense qu moines pour
n'importe quel alpiniste de l'époque ces
chiffres auraient été découragement 13
nord sahara et aucune réussite
[Musique]
environ 10 kilomètres au nord de tan
gauche se trouve le glacier de kumbo où
nous devions installer notre camp de
base principale pour attaquer la
montagne
étant donné que cette cascade de glace
allait être notre prochain grand
obstacle
j'ai envoyé une équipe en exploration et
ai dit larry était à sa tête
[Musique]
lacombe ouest est protégé par une très
grande cascade de glace
il s'agit d'un vin de glace 2 760 mètres
tombant du glacier de combos il nous
fallait d'abord déterminer s'il était
possible d'escalader cette cascade de
glace
le risque est permanent
mais nous n'avions pas d'autre
possibilité a pas me frayer un chemin
par lesquels n'étaient pas acceptables
et empreintes finissent me traditionnels
comme une cascade qui a gelé dans sa
chute le toit de l'acier fait pression
au dessus de nous cette annonce sonne
êtres humains de glace c'est instable
c'est un danger constant qu'on ne peut
pas prévoir
[Musique]
oui il fallait être fou pour tracer une
voie sur un chemin appareils il n'y
avait pas d'autre alternative que passer
par la cascade en 1952
les suisses avaient gravé la cascade et
avait dit qu'il était très instable
c'est ce qui en fait une étape aussi
dangereuse lacasse kahn a tué plus
d'hommes tout le reste de la presse
cet immense ça fait 760 mètres de haut
et nous devions grimper la moitié et
d'hillary georges au mic mac os avons
été choisis pour tracer la voie en une
semaine
en cinq jours si possible bien sûr le
vieux aussi sécuriser le chemin par de
nombreuses tailles de marché des cordes
le fixait pour ensuite permettre aux
porteurs d'acheminer les réserves en
toute sécurité
[Musique]
et la cascade était un passage dangereux
car des éboulements pouvait surgir à
tout instant mieux valait ne pas s'y
trouver au mauvais moment
[Musique]
il y avait des tours de glace des normes
blog gros comme des chalets qui pouvait
s'effondrer à tout moment
[Musique]
nous avons baptisé les passages les plus
dangereux la frayeur de mike la frayeur
d'hilario une zone s'appelait casse
noisette et une hotte la bombe atomique
il ya ce qu'on appelle des risques
objectifs pour lesquels on ne peut rien
faire
il y avait aussi le risque de tomber
dans une crevasse
on avait ces échelles légère en
aluminium d'environ 1 mètre 80 que l'on
pouvait assemblée pour traverser les
crevasses
[Musique]
mais il y avait tant de crevards ce
qu'on a vu était à cours d'échelle dû
redescendre des arbres à environ trois
jours de marche afin de couper de petit
rond pour en faire des passerelles
on tenait en équilibre comme on pouvait
[Musique]
pour nous ça devient le seul moyen de
gravier un vrai plus
et d'hillary voulait plaire il voulait
être dans l'équipe finale il savait que
seule une poignée d'entre eux auraient
la chance d'atteindre le sommet il a
cherché à impressionner johnson dès le
début il sentait que le temps pressait
qu'il fallait être assez rapidement une
voie sur la cascade
[Musique]
mon père n'a jamais eu peur de
travailler dur mais je pense que c'est
en partie pour combler les faiblesses
psychologiques il émotionnelle qu'il
croyait avoir
on attendait beaucoup de lui durant son
enfance par on avait envoyé la
houppelande grammar school avec deux ans
d'avancé je n'avait que 11 ans j'étais
plutôt terrifiés à l'heure du déjeuner
jallet derrière l'école il y avait un
tas de fourmi qui vivaient là quand je
suis arrivé à auckland g 1 mais c'est
l'ami étaient les fourmis j'étais un
rêveur à valence et d'alpinisme
[Musique]
le passage de la cascade a éclos
chaotique
cependant ils ont tracé une voie et aide
s'est montré particulièrement performant
dans son rôle d'éclaireur les néo
zélandais avec deux coups plus
d'expérience sur neige et sur glace
poulain clp mr guerre car leurs
montagnes ressemble davantage une
version miniature de l'himalaya
un peu du sud la grande chaîne de
montagne qui s'étend vers le nord dans
une suite presque ininterrompu de roche
et de glace
[Musique]
ed en quoi les alpes du sud 10 fertelle
des alpes suisses où les alpinistes
anglais vont s'entraîner ainsi en
nouvelle zélande l'alpinisme se fait
davantage sur neige et sur glace tout
comme el madania c'est très différent
des alpes suisses ubcs la sanction se
fait plutôt sur un laroche le moins
spirig le cervin et de nouvelle zélande
montagne forme de dents de requins dont
les chu une dangereuse demande de
l'expérience et beaucoup de prudence
mais montagne ou néo zélandaise sont un
formidable terrain d'entraînement pour
les médailles à l'équipe lit pour une
résistance tel que les jeunes alpinistes
anglais devait craindre l'arrivée de ces
formidables néo zélandais pour renforcer
l'équité
l'autre interrogation portait sur le
bord de la combe au sommet de la cascade
en effet il y avait là une énorme et
crevasses
ayumi pouvoir y passer
c'était le chef de l'expédition qui elle
choisir j'irais jusqu'au sommet johnny
depp à l'évaluer les clients tout au
long de l'expédition
il y avait donc pas mal de bluff au sein
de l'équipe car tous les hommes essayer
de se montrer sous leur meilleur jour
pour faire partie des privilégiés
[Musique]
selon - les britanniques ne jouait pas
forcément découdre mais je pense que
celle de deux néo zélandais il arrive il
y avait une vraie volonté d'aller le
plus loin possible
[Musique]
c'était en quelque sorte les coloniaux
qui s'en sortait plutôt bien je nombre
écoles privées nous étions peut-être un
peu plus libe je ne ferai pas mise en
avant à moins que je ne nous ai dit
allez c'est toi qui t'y col j'ai
toujours espéré que georges lot mais moi
serions le tandem finale pour
l'ascension mais en aucune façon notre
chef tournante
il aurait voulu appartenait aux landes
est au sommet de l'everest
il fallait donc que je cherche quelqu'un
qui soit aussi bon que moi et sur qui je
pouvais compter ce quelqu'un s'était ému
personne ne connaissait l'everest que
lui il avait conscience des enjeux
il savait que ça pouvait changer sa vie
rensing avait connu l'extrême pauvreté
il avait dû se battre il voulait envoyer
ses enfants dans de bonnes écoles
voulait leur offrir plus que ce qu'il a
vécu
dancing savez ce que représente l
ascension de l'everest
mon père était un peu bizarre pour un
sherpa
car il avait toujours voulu gravir
l'everest ce n'est pas très commun pour
un enfant pauvre d'un tibet
contrairement à de nombreux autres
sherpas qui ne font de l'alpinisme ce
que pour gagner leur vie
oui il avait une âme d'albi lost il
souhaitait réellement aller au sommet
tout comme lady lay
[Musique]
à mesure que nous avancions dans la
combe il y avait moins de crevasses et
où nous nous rendions compte que le
concert est à nous
[Musique]
nous sommes à présent sur le camp de
base et nous devons faire en sorte
d'acheminer nos provisions jusqu'au camp
4 un lot de lacombe ouest en raison des
difficultés d'ascension sur la cascade
de glace
il faudra trois jours aux porteurs pour
rejoindre le camp 4 à l'époque il
s'agissait véritablement d'assiéger la
montagne cela se faisait assez
mécaniquement ont installé un camp puis
un autre est comme ça jusqu'au sommet
cette succession de kant permet d'avoir
assez de tentes de nourriture de gaz
pour cuisiner d'oxygène d'avoir en somme
tout le nécessaire pour se reposer avant
de passer à l'étape suivante
[Musique]
pour ce faire les membres de
l'expédition devait monter et descendre
la montagne
dans l'idéal il monte jusqu'à un camp
pour ensuite redescendre car si tout le
monde reste en haut
les réserves de nourriture acheminée
s'épuise
le
[Musique]
les gens proposait les solutions pour
permettre à l'équipe d'atteindre le
sommet les gens du monde entier
envoyaient des idées d'invention
extravagant quelqu'un avait créé un
appareil ingénieux qui ressemblait à un
harpon avec un dispositif inflammable au
bout l'idée était de se frayer un chemin
dans la glace tout en garantissant une
certaine sécurité afin que l'équipe
puisse se hisser jusqu'aux sommets dans
la plupart des cas il s'agissait l'idée
complètement folle ma méthode consiste
en un câble fixé en amont par un avion
avec mon système de réchauffement
d'appoint de la température corporelle
l'air passe par une chambre de chauffage
et est ensuite on prépare un tube en
caoutchouc pour arriver jusqu'aux mains
au pied et à la tête
permettez moi de vous présenter mon
super pistolet pour planter décroché en
acier directement dans la paroisse je
propose d'équiper un manteau de laine
exactement comme pour une couverture
chauffante il doit être possible de
gravir la montagne à l'aide d'un gros
ballons remplis d'hélium
il faudrait alors prévoir une importante
quantité médiane
presque toutes les innovations
technologiques utilisés lors de
l'expédition de 1953 provenaient
d'invention militaire développé lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale l'équipement
résistant au vent qu'ils allaient porter
avait été testé dans la soufflerie de l'
usine d'aviation de farnborough 30
entreprises britanniques ont pris part à
la seule conception des bottes
l'ascension de l'everest de 1953 elle
était devenue une question de fierté
nationale
à la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
la grande bretagne était complètement
ruinée en raison de la politique
d'austérité d'après-guerre et d'étangs
terrible que le pays avait connu il
s'agissait là du dernier grand projet
colonial c'était le dernier cri de
victoire et l' empire britannique
[Musique]
mon père était ligue ont continué
d'offrir des niveaux allemands leur aide
à plusieurs reprises il voulait trouver
leurs compétences en tant qu'équipe en
lice dans la course au sommet mon père
était parfaitement conscient qu'à bien
des égards sa collaboration avec kensing
allait lui offrir la clé du succès il se
sentait tous les deux comme chez eux
dans cet environnement il rêvait du
sommet d'europe
un jour il était en binôme et il faisait
la course pour descendre la cascade de
glace de khumbu fait
histoire de prouver qu'il pouvait le
faire vite c'est épique d'un trop-plein
d'exubérance on se précipite et ça
tourne mal
redescendu vers le camp de base à miss
madonna cascade de glace nous sommes
arrivés à une crevasse
en moi sur le côté il y avait un gros
bloc de glace
nous en sommes servis comme tremplin
pour pouvoir traverser
nous
[Musique]
c'est quelque peu ironique qu'une telle
chose arrive à un aussi bon alpinistes
ken hillary les gens ont souvent dit tu
as dû être très reconnaissant envers
tenzing de pouvoir sauver la vie mais je
ne pense pas l'avoir échos j'aurais
plutôt été sacrément énervé s'il ne
l'avait pas fait
le camp 4 est maintenant installée et
nous avons réussi à y acheminer les
trois tonnes des provisions
m
bon
on ne conquiert pas une montagne les
filles on a de la chance très la
montagne qu'on nous donne l'opportunité
de nous tenir en son sommet il s'agit
d'essayer d'affronter nos propres
faiblesses
[Musique]
où
ed hillary déborder d'énergie il était
toujours devant
il voulait toujours être le bonheur ils
n'agissaient toutefois pas de façon
irréfléchie et conservait un tempérament
assez réservés mon père était une
personne compliqué je pense qu'il était
handicapé par son perfectionnisme lui
aussi par un complexe d'infériorité rien
n'était jamais c'est bien pour lui à mon
avis cela venait d'un environnement
familial plutôt complexe mon père ne
s'intéressait absolument pas à tout ce
qui touchait à l' aventure c'était un
homme ancré dans ce convictions
concernant l'alpinisme il devait penser
que c'était une perte de temps
[Musique]
on se disputait souvent lui général ils
finissaient par m'emmener dans l'abri à
bois pour me donner une bonne correction
[Musique]
je fais plutôt fier de ne jamais avoir
reconnu que j'avais tort
même quand c'était le cas
[Musique]
bien évidemment nous avions tous hâte de
savoir qu'il serait choisi pour la
dernière ligne droite
à cette époque le chef de l'expédition
avait toujours le dernier mot sur peu
pour des hommes qui avaient tous fait
l'armée la décision revenait à 1
c'est lui qui déciderait qui allait
avoir la chance de fouler le sommet de
l'everest
[Musique]
on était au camp de base et john and à
rassembler tout le monde pour faire part
de ses plans pour la suite de
l'expédition est bien sûr le point
essentiel t la conquête du sommet cette
réunion était extraordinaire
elle se composait d'hommes totalement
isolée du reste du monde qui se trouvait
à des milliers de kilomètres de chez eux
et ses hommes se disait tous la bonne
chose parce que je fasse partie des
chanceux on avait tous été choisis pour
nos études d'alpinistes il y avait aussi
bien d'autres tâches à exécuter
[Musique]
mon père était absolument certain qu'il
aurait une chance de gravir cette
montagne avoir la possibilité
d'atteindre le sommet et l île des
raisons pour lesquelles mon père avait
accepté d'accompagner l'équipe anglaise
il n'y avait aucun autre à la naissance
à giuly que lui on voulait tous avoir la
chance d'aller au sol mais le premier
essai allait très tenté par tonne lourd
dion et charles s et s'il fallait tenter
un second essai he ain't avait décidé
d'envoyer a dit larry et tenzing je suis
convaincu que mon père aurait adoré
faire partie de la première équipe
on est certainement contrarié
la prochaine étape qui est aussi la plus
importante part de la face du lot
jusqu'au col sud john caby bien tom
bourdillon et charles evans
on les enverra en premier en une journée
il peut faire une grande avancée du col
sud jusqu'au sommet
la première tâche cruciale de ce plan
revenait à georges lot il devait tracer
une voie le long de la phase du lot de
préparer le terrain pour l'acheminement
des provisions jusqu'au col cette étape
devait être achevée au 15 mai
il disait qu'il voulait être en mesure
de commencer l'ascension de l'everest au
15 mai t il avait constamment en tête
cette peur que la mousson arrive et met
fin à tous nos espoirs base il devait
d'abord franchir cet endroit appelé la
face du lot
cette inversion de glace et de neige qui
conduit en pente raide jusqu'au col sud
à 7900 25 mètres d'altitude
charles jeune compatriote néo zélandais
a dépensé beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
à tracer une voie sur ce terrain
dangereux
le travail sur cette section était très
compliquée et a été rendue encore plus
éprouvant par la météo les chutes de
neige quotidienne qui recouvrait le
parcours j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
dans ces sommets avec un imam à agir pas
extraordinaire
[Musique]
georges holleaux à travailler sur la
face du lot sans oxygène pendant plus
d'une semaine environ 7500 mètres
d'altitude
le froid et le vent était épouvantable
j'espérais constamment pouvoir finir la
traversée et le tracé de la voie
jusqu'au col sud mais j'ai été ralenti
par la météo et l'altitude m'affectait
on pensait ne jamais finir les centaines
de mètres qui nous séparait du col
john a commis l'erreur de sous-estimer
la face du loans
c'est une oreille
[Musique]
il aurait dû envoyer plus de renforts à
change non il n'y avait eu ni mas et moi
même quand ils ont fini par nous envoyer
des renforts au bout de 24 heures et
l'on pouvait déjà plus
[Musique]
en haute altitude on ne se sent jamais
très bien
chaque inspiration contient moins de
molécules d'oxygène
il nous faut donc plus d'inspiration
pour avoir une quantité d'oxygène
suffisante
mettez un coussin sur votre bouche
essayez de respirer au travers pourtant
courant vous manqués des desmans
d'oxygène cette rumeur jusqu'à ce que
vous en ayez plus du tout et la voûte et
vous arrêter il vous faut d'abord trois
ou quatre respiration par part puis 5
respiration ample et 6 puis case
respiration part pas brillé plus à
respirer
c'est comme si le cerveau accepte que
peut un peu de fonctionner au ralenti
j'avais l'impression de me sentir très
bien mais en réalité on titubait comme
si on était dans un monde irréel
[Musique]
nous avions passé dix jours sur la face
du lot donc plus que ce que j'escomptais
mais nous n'avions toujours pas franchi
le col sud
la situation devenait critique en terme
[Musique]
évaluons l'avancé sur la face du lot il
était évident que la progression c'est
conquérir le sommet allait être peu à
peu retardé les premiers signes d'une
housse on était déjà perceptible dans la
baie du bengale
c'était une étape vraiment critique on
percevait chez inde la peur que tout ce
grand projet tombe à l'eau mais aussi
que si on ne reprenait pas vite les
choses en main l'occasion aller nous
filer entre les doigts
la mousson à l'arrivée sont que l'on
atteigne le col sud et encore moins le
sommet ainsi londres pour l'expédition
de britanniques à l'everest
voici le dernier bulletin météo une
perturbation venant de l'ouest serait en
train de se déplacer vers l'est en
traversant l'extrême nord du népal cela
pourrait provoquer un ciel couvert à
nuageux ainsi que quelques orages
ponctuels
la plume est avancé plus nous avions de
chances d'être coincé par la mousson la
mousson provoquent d'énormes chutes de
neige qui compliquent encore davantage
d'attention qu'on ne peut rien gravé
avec de telles quantités de poudreuse
l'ascension est bien trop unis
l'expédition britannique des années 1930
avait échoué car la mousson était arrivé
en avance
tout cela nous mettait une sérieuse
pression
même si la voix n'était pas entièrement
achevées jusqu'au col sud a dû prendre
l'importante décision d'envoyer une
équipe de l'a14 sherpas pour acheminer
toutes les provisions nécessaires
[Musique]
ma rien ne doit mettre en péril la rive
et attend de nos provisions jusqu'au col
pour nos tentatives de conquête du
sommet
le 21 mai tenzin et moi avons mené un
groupe de quatorze sherpa sur la base du
lot
[Musique]
treize chefs pas en lutte et pour monter
sans oxygène jusqu'au col ce jour là le
14e n'a pas réussi et sa charge a été
répartie nous étions reconnaissants et
fiers d'eux faisait des journées de
10h30 porter 14 kilos chacun et ne
consommer qu'une tasse de thé par
personne au petit déjeuner
[Musique]
nous avons donc pu équiper correctement
le camp avec des tentes les sacs de
couchage les bouteilles d'oxygène et la
nourriture
c'était déjà une avancée considérable
[Musique]
le cône sud est sans doute l'un des
endroits les plus rudes un vent puissant
souffle sans arrêt sur les amas de
roches glace les vestiges des temps de
suivre que l'année précédente avec
quelques lambeaux de vêtements restée
accrochée ne faisait que renforcer
l'aspect désolante ce paysage
en 1952 les suisses avaient proposé à
mon père de grimper l'everest et il
était allé là où personne n'était allé
auparavant
mais les mauvaises conditions météo les
ont obligés à faire demi tour
je me souviens qu andré roques de
l'équipe suisse disait sur le col règne
une odeur de mort
on pensait qu'il en rajoute et 1 2 mais
une fois sur place on a compris
croyez moi on ressent le froid dans
chacune de nos ex cryptée on sait qu'on
va se geler les mains et les pieds de
sang le froid nous envahir
c'est une lutte entre notre corps est ce
qu'on espère pouvoir faire là haut on
sait qu'on meurt à petit feu
vous venez de passer à une étape majeure
il le fallait revenir à la con qu est
sans plus tarder il nous fallait lancer
notre plan attaque
voulait faire deux assauts sur le sol
mais il s'est rendu compte qu'il ne
pourrait pas réaliser de tentatives avec
des appareils respiratoires à circuit
ouvert avec un circuit vert quand on
expire claire explorer va dans
l'atmosphère et quand on inspire une
dose de la bouteille d'oxygène s'ajoute
à l'air atmosphérique les appareils à
circuit ouvert consomment beaucoup
d'oxygène
il aurait donc fallu une énorme quantité
d'oxygène pour aller jusqu'au col sud
puis jusqu'à l'arête sud est il a donc
dû se dire que ce n'était pas faisable
mais il existait un autre type
d'appareil respiratoire qu'on appelait à
circuit fermé en circuit fermé lors de
l'expiration le dioxyde de carbone passe
à travers un compartiment contenant ce
qu'on appelle de la chaux sauder qui
extraient le dioxyde de carbone et
réapprovisionnent l'appareil en oxygène
ainsi on obtient une parfaite isolation
avec l'air extérieur
s'il fonctionne le circuit fermé est
peut être plus efficace que le système à
circuit ouvert le système à circuit
fermé peut être utilisée à plus basse
altitude
toutefois la spécificité de ce système
était que la seule personne qui savait
vraiment comment utiliser cet équipement
n'était autre que celle qu'il avait
conçu à savoir tom bourdillon est
précisément le premier essai pour
atteindre le sommet à l'aide du système
à circuit fermé allait être réalisée par
tom bourdillon et charles evans john
holt se tiendraient sur le col sud en
renfort
[Musique]
et 26 bourdillon quitté le camp de base
situé sur la côte ouest
ils ont remonté le col sud pour camper
tom et charles devait remonter tout le
col sud jusqu'au sommet je pensais
qu'ils avaient une chance d'y arriver
mais c'était un sacré longs trajets
si bourdillon evans atteignent le sommet
john hunt pourrait dire mission
accomplie
on rentre tous chez nous sains et saufs
mais le mauvais temps nous a surpris
mais nous avons tous été bloqué pendant
2 jours y compris bourdy en evans sur le
col sud
mon père était zig ont quitté le camp de
base sur lacombe reste ils ont rejoint
le pôle sud pour se tenir prêt comme
deuxième équipe pour atteindre le sommet
nous avons donc quitté le camp de base
dans la coupe
il y avait notre équipe de renfort
georges le half grégory et plusieurs
sherpa tenzing et moi étions l'équipe de
tête avec les systèmes respiratoire à
circuit ouvert
alors que mon père était ligue partait
du camp 4 bourdillon evans tentaient
d'atteindre le sommet nous avons remonté
la face du globe c'est traverser le long
chemin qui mène au conte sud
nous étions presque arrivés en haut du
col quand nous avons aperçu les kills de
rendre georges s'est mis à crier à ceux
qui partout nous avons levé les yeux et
nous avons vu et vallées bourdillon est
remonté le tout typique - devant demain
à eau du sommet sud
il devait être aux alentours de midi et
nous nous sommes dit ils sont au sommet
sud
amélie ils ont le temps d'aller jusqu'au
bout
ils vont l'atteindre
et jean bourdillon et 27 étaient hors de
vue cela a suscité de vives émotions car
ces hommes-là voulait vraiment atteindre
le sommet
nous avons tous suivi jusqu'au col sud
un peu plus tard dans la journée nous
avons marqué l'arrivée des nuages sur la
montagne
nous étions un peu inquiet pour évincer
bourdillon mais vers 3 heures et demie
environ
georges les à nouveau vu redescendre le
couloir de l'arête sud est jusqu'au col
sud
cela faisait déjà longtemps qu'ils
avaient commencé à redescendre
la descente les avaient énormément
épuise les toiles
[Musique]
lorsque pour d'ions evans sont
redescendus mon père est allé
directement les voir
la plupart des gens ont eu tendance à
voir ça comme une marque de soutien bien
intentionnés et c'était totalement ça
mais d'autres pensaient qu'au fond tout
ce que souhaitait mon père c'était
gravir cette montagne et qu'ils
voulaient simplement savoir jusqu'où il
était allé ils nous ont dit qu'ils
avaient atteint le sommet sud sans
problème et avaient aperçu l'arête du
sommet et qu'ils avaient manqué tant
d'oxygène et d'énergie pour aller plus
loin
[Musique]
il était dans un état déplorable
charles evans avait passé la journée
avec un appareil respiratoire défectueux
il inhale est alors autant de dioxyde de
carbone que d'oxygène je pense aussi que
tom bourdillon était très affecté
psychologiquement car vous savez ça
représentait beaucoup pour lui
c'est lui qui avait conçu ce système à
oxygène qui leur avait fait tant défaut
il était donc très affecté aussi bien
physiquement que moralement comme
bourdillon répétait on aurait dû y aller
on aurait dû continuer on aurait
vraiment dû continuer
evans et bourillon la fédé alpinistes
solide et expérimenté il est n étaient
plus que n'importe qui avant il avait
atteint le sommet sud est avait aperçu
cette crête à charles evans a même dit à
m il arrive quelque chose comme cette
dernière arrête a vraiment l'air
difficile je ne sais pas si vous y
arrivez
[Musique]
au-delà de cette 1900 mètres d'altitude
c'est la zone de la mort car on y meurt
peu à peu cet endroit n'est pas faits
sont là
johnson qui était un chef qui menait
depuis l'avant et comme l'avant était
alors au dessus du pôle sud
il tenait à rester là bas mais nous nous
étions rendus compte qu'ils n'allaient
pas pouvoir continuer bien l'autre
c'était l'exemple typique d'une personne
qui avait été trop trop longtemps il
était allé au delà de ses limites comme
tom bourdillon et charles evans si on
est parvenu à les faire redescendre tous
les trois ils étaient épuisés
on était inquiet pour eux il a même
fallu leur donner un peu d'oxygène pour
les aider je ne voulais pas partir mais
après ma conversation je me suis rendu
compte que je ne pouvais pas me
permettre de ralentir la deuxième équipe
j'ai donc quitté aide avec pour seule
consigne de ne pas abandonner c'était un
moment important de l'expédition
le chef sacrifier sa propre ambition est
d larry disait je n'ai jamais ressenti
autant de respect envers john phan qu'à
ce moment là
[Musique]
c'était très délicat car la mousson
arrivée la première semaine de juin
le timing était serré à la proche des
derniers jours de mai pour atteindre le
sommet hillary et tenzing ne pouvait pas
passer par le col sud car il aurait dû
porter trop d'oxygène
la seule solution était de commencer
plus lourd et ensuite d'attaquer le
sommet le jour suivant avait été
extrêmement froides de aucune ascension
n'était possible
nous avons passé la journée à préparer
l'oxygène et le matériel dans l'espoir
commun serait plus clément ils devaient
utiliser de l'oxygène la nuit à très
faible débit pour les aider à dormir et
à se réchauffer la nuit est rude
on est couché on écoute la montagne
les coupes le vent le bruit des
avalanches et on se dit que c'est
effrayant les pires pensée mots viennent
en principe grégory et 3 cherpin devait
porter le camp en altitude
sherpa s'est évanoui sur le col et a dû
redescendre il nous restait alors deux
sherpas
le matin du jour où l'on devait tenter
de transporter tout l'équipement
nous avons passé la tête dans la teinte
et y avons trouvé le sherpa pemba en
très mauvais état il était évident qu'il
ne pourrait rien porter et que nous
allions devoir nous répartir les charges
tout d'abord très tôt le matin nous
avons dû réorganiser les charges et
emporter davantage georges lot en climat
et moi même sommes partis vers 20h45
[Musique]
et de tenzing ont quitté le col sud
une heure après non pour préserver leur
énergie avancer plus vite sur nos pas et
ainsi conserver leur oxygène on est donc
parti importante aux 22 et 27 kg chacun
on a estimé qu elle emporté 28 inuit ce
qui est une charge énorme à cette
altitude
le vent soufflait très fort sur l'école
les conditions étaient très ride on a
remonté ses tares est à la recherche
d'une zone plane
[Musique]
on a mis très longtemps à trouver un
endroit pour camper ce fut finalement
ten things qui en a trouvé un une zone
presque plane surplombée d'une falaise
rocailleuse ils nous ont aidé à établir
le camp le plus élevé jamais installé
sur l'everest avis sur n'importe quel
autre montagne 8500 mètres d'altitude
personne n'avait jamais campé six ans
[Musique]
l'oréal grégory ont pris quelques photos
puis on salue l'équipe de tête en disant
au revoir
bonne chance on ferait mieux de
redescendre et il ya un moment
merveilleusement tout en images les
traits fatigués ils devaient redescendre
mais le dit à mon père qu'il voulait
rester pour les aider lorsqu'ils
redescendrait et leur faire lutter je
sais que mon père on avait été très
touché
mais finalement ils sont distingués en
laissant hillary et tenzing livre elle
c'était plutôt douloureux de voir george
grey goulinat décembre dernier tallien
blessé tout seul
nous aurions vraiment préféré avoir un
peu de compagnie dans la nuit devaient
redescendre car nous commencions à
manquer d'oxygène
vous êtes complètement seul totalement
isolé il n'y aucun contact radio il vous
pourriez disparaître et personne ne
serait ce qui a bien pu vous arriver
c'est un défi excitant
un défi sanitaire c'est un défi
l'effrayant
il nous a fallu deux heures pour monter
la tente sur deux bandes de terrain de
90 cm de large sur 3 mètres de long
vers le sommet de l'everest
on doit affronter des vents vraiment
très puissant et hillary et tenzing
était attaché très très clairement sur
ce versant il y risque est constamment
d'être arraché de la montagne quand le
vent se lève le soir la situation est
très dangereuse car on doit rester
clouée à la montagne le bruit est
vraiment effrayant
cette nuit-là a été la plus froide que
l'on ait connu de toute l'expédition
c'est un environnement très déshydratant
il n'y a qu'une façon de faire de l'eau
il faut faire fondre de la neige de la
grâce on respire huit fois plus qu'au
niveau de la mer on peut perdre plus
d'un litre d'eau par jour
rien qu en respirant en haute altitude
en plus les récits sec qu'il dessert
complètement la pique
je me suis mis à l'aise autant que faire
se peut à moitié assi à moitié allongé
sur leurs bords je n'étais pas
confortable mais je pouvais au moins
redresser mes pieds et mes épaules pour
maintenir les piquets de la tente lors
des rafales de vent
en alpinisme de haute altitude il s'agit
de dénicher un peu de confort dans des
endroits inconfortable il était très
doué pour la survie alimentaire au
quotidien tout comme tenzing je pense
que son parti pour ça qu'ils sont si
bien sorti les ventes tombées tôt dans
la nuit
on avait de l'oxygène que l'on utilisait
pour dormir pendant environ quatre des
seize heures qu'un pas souffert durant
ces quatre heures au moins nous
réussissions d'ordinaire dès que
l'oxygène arrêtait ont été réveillés par
la sensation de froid
il se disait constamment je ne veux pas
utilisé l'oxygène de demain il y avait
eu un petit problème il avait emporté
une énorme bouteille d'oxygène noire
qu'ils avaient l'intention d'utiliser la
nuit mais malheureusement après avoir
monté la bouteille ils se sont rendus
compte que quelqu'un était reparti avec
l'adaptateur adéquat la bouteille était
donc inutilisable à vrai dire je n'étais
pas sûr que nous allions réussir
je savais très bien que d'excellentes
expédition avait tenté cette ascension
était un mot très haut mais sans pour
autant réussir
[Musique]
6h30 du matin nous sommes mis en route
nous n'avons pas tardé à préparer le
dispositif l'oxygène et l'équipement à
ce stade tout est une question de sigen
hillary se répéter sans cesse de combien
d'oxygène et je me sois quel doit être
le débit d'eau seychelles si je
m'autorise un débit supérieur
je me sens mieux mais je consomme plus
vite la bouteille
[Musique]
il faisait vraiment très froid on
estimait que la température était en
dessous des -30 degrés celsius
ce type de froid glacial vous agresse
littéralement cet affreux le physiologue
de l'équipe disert quand on monte en
haute altitude
il faut régler l'appareil à oxygène sur
4 litres par minute en dessous ça ne
servirait presque rien notre progression
était plutôt constante au début mais en
observant les réserves d'oxygène on leur
dise et qu'on ne pouvait pas utiliser
les 4 nick par minute qu'on avait prévu
si vous voulez avoir une chance
d'arriver au sommet on a dû baisser le
débit à 3 litres même un calcul
relativement simple du débit d'oxygène
devient incroyablement difficile là haut
car le cerveau est ralentie à cause du
manque d'oxygène
[Musique]
on
après avoir marché un certain temps nous
sommes arrivés en bas d'une pente de 120
mètres de haut qui menait au sommet sud
c'était une tante extrêmement escarpé
on sentait qu'il pourrait bien y avoir
une avalanche la neige former une couche
fine ce qui donnait l'impression d'être
sur un sol ferme mais ça pouvait céder à
tout moment c'était certainement
poudreux en dessous s'inquiéter hillary
qui redoutaient une avalanche puis ils
ont eu cette discussion
je me souviens être tournés vers tenzing
de lui avoir demandé qu'est ce que tu en
penses
il m'a dit que ça ne lui disait rien qui
vaille ils trouvaient ça vraiment
dangereux je lui ai demandé qu'est ce
que tu en penses tu crois qu'on devrait
continuer et il a répondu
lancé comme tu veux nous avons grimpé
cette pente
je pense que c'était la première fois
que je décide est ce une situation était
raisonnable non je savais que ce n'était
pas raisonnable mais nous avons quand
même continuer
on est à la limite du possible ils
risquent leur vie à chaque pas la
tentation de faire demi tour et de
redescendre est forte quand je suis en
terrain dangereux la plupart du temps je
suis terrifié mais je pense que la peur
est un élément essentiel à ce que la
peur stimule on s'est bien entendu si
elles nouent pétrifie alors ça ne sert à
rien
la question est de pouvoir survivre
aune là haut rien n'est moins sûr au
sommet la moindre chose qui tourne mal
le moindre incident peut très vite
s'avérer fatale ce fut un grand
soulagement quand on a atteint le sommet
sud à 9 heures du matin comme l'oxygène
commençait à manquer nous l'avons pas
trop laid comme nous sommes attaqués à
la crête
mais nous avancions lentement et le
tangage ou est pas en notre faveur
26 bourdillon était allé jusqu'au sommet
sud est avait émis des réserves sur le
chemin qu'il reste à parcourir
evans avait dit qu'il y avait une arête
particulièrement abrupte en dents de
scie avec du précipice terrifiant de
chaque côté il devait simplement se
demander s'il allait pouvoir la franchir
ou non
sur la gauche il y à l'immense face sud
ouest de l'everest en cas de chute
on dégringolerait jusqu'à lacombe
l'ouest 2450 mètres plus bas et sur la
droite se trouve le précipice encore
plus abyssal de la phase du coaching
ça fait vraiment réfléchi
un alpiniste penser au processus complet
d'une mort éventuelle est encore pire
que le fait même de se dire qu'on risque
de ne pas s'en sortir
pendant ce temps nous observons d'en bas
depuis le camp 4 et nous étions tous
très anxieuse
évidemment on aurait aimé avoir notre
petit talkie walkie au moins jusqu'au
col sud
mais celui qui avait été emportée là bas
ne fonctionnait pas nous avons alors
réalisé qu'elle ne serions même pas si
hillary et tenzing avaient réussi avant
qu'il ne redescende pour nous la lancée
et ni personne ne savait où se trouvait
comment il allait s'il fallait réussir
une même s'il allait revenir
notre équipement d'oxygène n'était pas
perfectionner il ne comportait qu'une
chose de pression je ne savais donc
jamais vraiment un bien d'oxygène il me
restait mon cerveau fonctionne est plus
que bien et je pouvais encore calculer
combien de temps il lui restait
l'un des problèmes majeurs en alpinisme
de très haute altitude et le risque de
défaillance du système d'oxygène de
nombreux alpinistes meurt quand leur
oxygène les lâches et puis il y a eu un
problème tensing rencontré des
difficultés alors qu'il avait toujours
suivi hillary sans problème tout à coup
j'ai remarqué que tenzin y avait l'air
en détresse je me suis alors approché de
lui et j'ai vu qu'il respire est
vraiment très fort j'ai tout de suite
vérifier son oxygène et j'ai vu que la
ventilation de son masque était presque
complètement bouché par de la glace
mais heureusement j'ai pu la retrouver
on tombe soudainement en hypoxie et on
n'a plus les idées claires on ne pense
pas forcément anciens c'est parce que
mon oxygène ne fonctionne pas bien on se
dit simplement
mince je me sens vraiment fatigué tout
d'un coup
[Musique]
tous en flux d'image flou bizarre voire
irréel et tout un tas de penser nous
traverse l'esprit
ça il faut donc faire très attention à
soi et aux autres
[Applaudissements]
après environ une heure on avait
traversé une grande partie de la crète
et on est arrivé à une falaise rocheuse
qui lui barrait la route à ce moment là
j'ai vraiment pensé que ce serait
peut-être le plus loin conduire et j'ai
pris des photos car la roche était
vraiment très abrupte or il était
conscient que ça pouvait nous arrêter
wang dan s il était même possible de
franchir ce ressort surtout à une
attitude de 8790 m
personne n'avait atteint cet auteur
auparavant c'était un sacré resson en
voyant on se dit que c'est une énorme
décision à prendre mais et d'april
risques et c'est dire bon sens allez
j'espère
fresnoy le seul moyen de monter et de
passer par une crevasse sous la glace
était bien fixé à la roche mais je
n'étais même pas sûr que la classe
tiendrait pour mu serait
j'étais leur faveur
il s'est donc attelé à se re so et s'est
hissé dans cette cheminée c'est qui est
cramponné s'appuyer contre la roche sur
la gauche et son dos poucet contre la
neige du côté droit il priait pour que
la neige ne sais pas et le projette à
3350 mettre en bas de la face du camping
car il était peu probable que l'orgueil
puisse le retenir avec la corde en cas
de chute
mais bon
de petits blocs commencé à se détacher
mon père n'était pas vraiment dans les
meilleures conditions
et s'il avait été dans les alpes du sud
il aurait probablement fait demi-tour et
préféré essayer un autre jour mais il
devait écouter cette petite voix dans sa
tête qui lui disait aide c'est l'everest
il faut que tu ailles le plus loin
possible
en prenant appui sur la glace avec les
crampons dans les bottes et en utilisant
la moindre prise je suis parvenu à force
de contorsions juste en haut de la
crevasse
[Musique]
après avoir repris me suffit que j'ai
attrapé la corde et en tirant très fort
j'ai tué l'été n'zinga se hisser de la
même manière
il y a des fois dans la vie où il faut
être courageux et déterminé on comptait
beaucoup sur la capacité d'hillary à
tout mettre en oeuvre pour réussir et il
avait dépassé nos espérances
dû redescendre du col sud
il a regardé aide et lui a dit écoute
c'est notre dernière chance tu porte
l'espoir de beaucoup de gens sur tes
épaules quel est ton faire s'il est
échoué
on y pensait tous et surtout john holt
mais je crois bien que personne n'osait
en parler
nous on continue et plus on était
fatigués désespéré le sommet semblait
nous échapper un rassemblement après le
ressaut d'hillary il reste encore un
long chemin à parcourir jusqu'au sommet
il fallait encore traversé trois ou
quatre uniques et quand il arrivait en
passer 1
il y en avait un autre derrière ils
devaient se demander si allez en voir le
bout un jour
[Musique]
il n'y a que peu d'êtres humains qui
sont psychologiquement capable de faire
ça de continuer à mettre un pied devant
l'autre sans relâche nombreux sont ceux
qui auraient offert
[Musique]
on a taillé des marches jusqu'en haut en
bravant toutes les aspérités sur notre
passage sans jamais perdre de vue le
sommet et nous l'avons finalement
atteint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que j'ai regardé tenzing et même
avec son masque à oxygène et sa cagoule
je pouvais deviner son grand sourire
communicatif
l'innocent serrer la main mais pour
tenzin ce n'était pas assez
c'est alors taper dans le dos jusqu'à
manquer d'air j'ai jeté un coup d'oeil à
ma montre
il était 11h30
[Musique]
je ne restait qu'un quart d'heure nous
avions constamment à l'esprit que notre
oxygène étaient comptés et qu'il n'y
avait pas de temps à perdre il devions
descendre
j'ai enlevé mon masque pour pouvoir
faire quelques photos
zig à creuser un petit trou dans la
neige dans laquelle il a déposé une
offrande pour les dieux
on a bien admirer la vue j'ai même pris
quelques photos des principales arrête
de la montagne l'espoir d'avoir des
preuves de notre réussite
[Musique]
lui j'ai photographié tenzing en train
d'agiter 5 violet sur lequel ils avaient
accroché quatre drapeaux
nous vivions tous les deux un moment
formidable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rannou
ici
c'est que ce soit de méforme
[Musique]
sauf que
non
il se met
regardez
besancenot
merci
[Musique]
à
l'eau
et
ce pays
là
[Musique]
vis ma campagne
pharmacies
au mama
hes so qu'une femme elle attendait
chrono est sous briquet
et une et solent
obama
mais bien
[Musique]
et
voilà
[Musique]
m
tout ça
besoin d'un truc à fond
la nuit
[Musique]
je
je voulais
le samoa
[Musique]
jeudi
cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
[Musique]